in the weeks after in a very simplified
way your brain is literally growing a
bit we call that neuroplasticity
so which helps you on the one side to
develop habits or to get rid of habits
so it's extremely helpful if you want to
get off an addiction
stuff like that but also if you look at
brains after
the people seem to be more creative
yeah and also more
again it's very more open for the world
yeah so that is one one big part is that
sort of
realization of your true self of your
also the negatives also the painful ones
so it's incredibly
trauma healing which is by the way and i
have to say
more often like a trip must not be
nice it's not a party trip it's nothing
you want to do
at a disco yeah so it can be each
our sake okay extremely cleansing yeah
but you're always going to feel better
after yeah and i actually
had uh very colloquially we say bad
trips
but i like the word more challenging
trips but they were actually the nicest
or the best ones not the nicest one of
the best ones
because they gave me so much because i
learned so much about
again fears whatever which you're trying
to hide very
somewhere yeah and you dissolve them so
that's one thing and the second big
thing
what also happens is
you feel connected to nature
and other humans in a way you can't
describe and one other form so
so there are several sources of mental
health issues
if i be oversimplified the one i already
said is fear
and trauma yeah and the other one is
lost connections
a lot of people feel disconnected from
everything
from the world from from people whatever
and psychedelics bring
back that enormous sort of love
for the creation if i want to say now
it's like for humans animals this is why
by the way
this is why a lot of people go vegan
after that or at least say i want to be
more responsible
towards my environment and then the
third part is very interesting and that
is
maybe at least all of these things are
very i think
helping in what i said to de-traumatize
the world
um the third one is in the weeks after
in a very simplified way your brain is
literally growing a bit we call that
neuroplasticity
um so which helps you
on the one side to develop habits
or to get rid of habits so it's
extremely helpful if you want to get off
an addiction
stuff like that but also if you look at
brains after
the people seem to be more creative
yeah and also more
again it's very more open for the world
and i think what we
all have to have to go into this time
with the same mental health is like this
or like this sort of
the future is gonna be fine like we just
need to find out
so but if you tell that a 60 year old
even leave away whatever the job is like
some so unfortunately if you look at the
brain
we people always think of the aging of
the body but our brain round about when
you're 30
is starting to age not just in a sort of
mental capacity that you're losing
gradually a little bit like
but also you're literally closing down
like if you go like in an old people's
home
why do people not make friends you would
say they have time they have the whole
day they should make a lot of friends
yeah
you literally can't your brain is not
wired anymore
so you make your friends in your 20s
yeah when you're open when so so really
for example all my friends i have but
actually i make new friends all the time
because i think i'm always a lot of
psychedelics like
so psychedelic facts that create we
became friends in the last two years now
i don't know if you were tripping at the
time but
yeah so so no so well honestly like so
so you get back this sort of
openness for the world yeah and so
yeah so and these three things if i look
at what we need a
we need to have the discussion that we
let's say the elite or we as the one we
need to offer
a world where these people i said like
the sort of the lower level jobs
where we find new jobs for them but at
the same time we need to make sure that
they want it by the way so and again
telling a 60 year old look you know what
you go back to university
even if he mentally if he intellectually
can
he doesn't have that impetus anymore
with 60.
however he could have it maybe yeah uh
with uh
psychedelics right it's like it's like
telling it's like telling a journalist
to learn to code
i guess that's a a big problem maybe
yeah
maybe if you uh get a little bit of help
and by the way one
many example it becomes not too esoteric
where the uk
as the first country i think the first
country recognized
loneliness as a disease um
and especially in old people and it's
literally by the way if
you look at the health data of people
who are lonely at any age
their health is dramatically uh
getting worse because we're pac animals
so if we are alone our stress level goes
up permanently we're so
we're going to get depressive which is
again depression has an impact on our
immune system so there is a
really a downward spiral so so
they're not saying yet that depression
should be sorry that
that loneliness should be treated with
psychedelics but the first
step is always to speak it out and say
okay loneliness is a disease
because now we can start going to the
regulators and saying hey
maybe we can prove you in a proper
clinical study
that psychedelics also might heal not
just depression what we are about to
prove
but like also loneliness and stuff like
that and
and i think again coming back to the
beginning there will be some when
a disease again we need a cool name for
it or cool but but like
which is that a fear of the future yeah
and
and and again then once we have named it
we can maybe run clinical trials
and we can bring the ball in motion
yeah i mean i'm so with you on this that
i think you're right people have this
sort of
existential dread about the future it
feels like the past is kind of broken
and they're just like oh they can't even
see what is in the future so
for people that know nothing about this
i think they're probably going wait a
minute wait a minute does this guy just
want me to be tripping on mushrooms all
day so what does
what does like an actual uh
way of life look like incorporating some
of this stuff like
are people just micro dosing all day
long so micros is uh
okay let's leave the mic because it's a
complex answer like let's stay with
what what we are doing so i have a
company just ipod
which is called atai atai
and we have more than 10 new mental
health drugs most of them
psychedelic in development so what we're
doing we're taking actually
either we have a lot of elect what we
call anecdote level so i'm always
careful because like
i know that i had these amazing not just
one trip yeah and i know many friends
but
in a scientific view this is still
anecdotal it's like alright
at the same time i know to be fair like
there are thousands of reports and
thousands so and some of these drugs
actually interestingly
in the last millennia uh in in the last
century were
legal again or medically available for
depression and stuff like that but it's
sort of old data but what we are doing
we're taking these
anecdotal and partly historic so to say
evidence
and really doing and this is important
very rigorous
really state-of-the-art clinical trials
on the fda
and european supervision yeah in order
to really prove it at the moment i have
to say
look i do think magic mushrooms
potentially
or or ketamine or ibuka you know all the
psychedelics dmt 5ml dmt
yeah so i have to potentially say
because it's
in a sort of scientific way not too bad
but we proving it now once and for all
and we are actually with some of them
already in phase two which is like sort
of pretty advanced for biotech
yeah somewhere a little bit earlier
stage um but sort of i would say within
the next five
six years yeah hopefully
some of our drugs will be approved so
and then this is important they're gonna
be
medically available not for take it home
not on prescription but that you go to
your psychotherapist
or your doctor yeah and you do the trip
with him or her which is important
because you need a guide actually when
you look where these drugs coming from
they were used since thousands of years
in
ritualistic shamanistic religious way
so you always had a priest or a shaman
with the disciple
and kind of can say the the
the psychotherapists are the shamans of
our time yeah so but that's important so
we don't we want to have it in this
kind of restricted access not because
i think ultimately big parts of humanity
will
will sort of benefit from it but it's
very it's a very powerful drug so it's
not that you it's not like a
aspirin you pop it and you find like
again part of the process
is really touching your deepest fears
your
all of that yeah so you have to do it
with a psychotherapist
uh but that's what we want to make
available and i think we are in a good
way of it
yeah this may sound like an amateur
question but is everything that you're
testing right now is it all actually
natural substances or is any of it made
in a lab
um not all of it like so
some of the substances we have in our
portfolio at a tie
are originally nature substances
but in any case may they be natural
originally
or some of them are like take mdma which
is a synthetic drug from the beginning
there is a nature
natural mma so both yeah but in any case
we are just using the synthetic version
because you need to be precise in
quality and dosage so you can't
you will not have homegrown magic
mushrooms
in a hospital with a doctor because you
need an exactly
for a for a patient you want a clean and
perfect version yeah if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about tech instead of
non-stop yelling check out our tech
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell